[Applaus]
[Musik]
welches land war das erste aus der welt
dass ein impfstoff gegen das virus
entwickelt hat
wer hats erfunden genau ausland und es
nannte sein vakzins publikum
russland schlug die gesamte globale
pharmaindustrie allerdings kamen mit
diesem impfstoff eine erneute debatte
auf können die in der russischen
medizintechnik überhaupt vertrauen viele
länder sind davon gar nicht überzeugt
[Musik]
brasilien lehnte ab und moskau gibt die
schuld dafür den usa und brasilien ist
nicht das einzige land wieder die
europäische union noch die vereinigten
staaten haben diesen impfstoff
zugelassen und die frage ist warum sie
derart misstrauen gegenüber den
impfstoff aus putin land gibt es da für
medizinische gründe oder handelt es sich
einfach um eine ideologische und
machtpolitische fragen
und das ist noch nicht alles der
russische impfstoff viele weitere fragen
auf zum beispiel diese hier putin
unterstützt den verzicht russlands auf
patente für seinen impfstoff erst mal
eine sekunde darüber nach warum solltet
putin das patent auf seinen eigenen
impfstoff aufgeben wollen schließlich
könnte russland ein vermögen damit
machen seinen impfstoff weltweit zu
verkaufen nun am ende dieses weges wirst
du genau wissen warum und alle
zusammenhänge verstehen denn die haben
es durchaus in sich in der zwischenzeit
müssen wir aber die andere grosse frage
klären funktionierte sputnik v wirklich
oder handelt es sich um einen russischen
propaganda-trick nun das einzige worauf
wir uns verlassen können sind peer
reviewed wissenschaftliche publikationen
und die wellen ein eindeutiges urteil
[Musik]
februar 2020 müssen sich airlines hat
eine studie mit 20.000 teilnehmern
sie zeigte dass der impfstoff eine
wirksamkeit von 91,6 prozent hat mit
anderen worten ja alles deutet darauf
hin dass der russische brennstoff
funktioniert allerdings gibt es bis
heute nur 64 länder die es zugelassen
haben
die meisten davon sind in lateinamerika
dem nahen osten und afrika die am
meisten entwickelten länder der welt
trauern russisch medizin immer noch
nicht überdeckt und das alles erscheint
sehr verdächtig immerhin war es gut mit
v der erste verfügbare impfstoff
überhaupt sind den regierungen die das
russische aktien abnehmen also ihre
eigenen machtspielchen wichtiger als das
leben ihrer eigenen bürger im august
2020 als die ganze welt verzweifelt nach
einem impfstoff sucht präsentierte
russlands einen kandidaten und selbst
monate und 10.000 tote später
debattierten sohn europa als auch die
vereinigten staaten immer noch darüber
ob sie einsetzen sollen oder nicht
und viele von euch werden natürlich
denken dass das ganz gewaltig nach
doppelmoral riecht immerhin wurden der
kaiserberg impfstoff und der moderne
einem stoff innerhalb weniger wochen
nach ihrer ankündigung zugelassen was
ist also das problem mit den russischen
aktien wegen dir hier überhaupt noch
über wissenschaft oder nur noch über
reine politik wie war es überhaupt
möglich dass russland der ganzen welt
zuvor kam und warum will putin auf das
patents verzichten heute haben wir an
diese frage natürlich beantworten aber
zuerst werden wir hierzu einen kurzen
blick auf ein bisschen geschichte werfen
made in russia die erste frage der
wahrscheinlich stellst ist woher kommt
überhaupt der name ist mutig er schwört
erinnerungen herauf an russlands
schönste stunden und deshalb heißt die
russische internationale
nachrichtenagentur auch und der
impfstoff den russland der welt
verkaufen will heißt es und nix aber ist
die russische wissenschaft wirklich so
mächtig wie sie sich gibt nun die
wahrheit ist ja sie ist es weiß dass zum
beispiel wer den ersten atomreaktor der
welt entwickelt hat nein es waren keine
amerikanischen wissenschaftler sondern
egon krenz ein russischer
wissenschaftler und er ist nicht der
einzige
russland hat viele der besten
wissenschaftler der weltgeschichte
hervorgebracht und ich weiß was viele
von euch denken wie ist das überhaupt
möglich war die ubs ist ehrlich so etwas
wie motto wollt ihr uns auf einmal
weismachen dass der kommunismus
funktioniert hat nun der vorteil einer
zentralisierten volkswirtschaft ist dass
der staat wenn er sich mal entscheidet
in eine bestimmte technologie zu
investieren eine menge geld auf einmal
investieren kann genau das haben sie im
kommunismus gemacht und sie machen es
auch gunter punkte das ist der grund
warum russischen waffen suchen so wie
zum beispiel die spd ihren us-kunden
ebenbürtig ist und ähnlich verhält es
sich auch mit dem gamma laizität
[Musik]
merke dir diesen namen gut denn dies ist
die tv entwickelt das institut wurde
1891 gegründet und 919 verstaatlicht im
westen war bisher nicht viel über dieses
staatliche forschungszentrum bekannt und
das ist auch nicht verwunderlich
russland ist nicht gerade dafür bekannt
seine forschungsaktivitäten in alle welt
hinauszuposaunen ja auch eine tradition
aus der zeit als die kapitalistischen
pharmaunternehmen noch mit anderen
kommerziellen medikamenten und nicht mit
impfstoffen beschäftigt waren
vorstellen kann er ja bereits impfstoffe
studierende ebola die in den
entwicklungsländern wüteten ebola in
afrika zu heilen ist für ein privates
unternehmen unrentabel aber germania ist
nicht auf kommerziellen profit
angewiesen was ihnen hier einen
wettbewerbsvorteil verschafft hat eins
zu null spiel staatswirtschaft gegen
marktwirtschaft ist gleich um geld für
die finanzierung da die wirtschaft so
zentralisiert ist hat der staat eine
menge geld das er dort einsetzen kann wo
es gebraucht wird wie genau sind sie
also vorgegangen um das zu beantworten
müssen die rhein maas vorstellen der die
volle rückendeckung des kremls liest das
ist kirill dmitriev ukraine 25 jahre alt
hat an den renommiertesten universitäten
der vereinigten staaten studiert dann
aber den usa den rücken gekehrt und ist
der ceo des russischen staatsfonds sowie
norwegen sein start vor hat das auch
russland ein wenn auch eine viel
kleinere dennoch ist er groß genug um
zehn milliarden dollar in die
entwicklung eines impfstoffs zu
investieren auf den die ganze welt
wartet
die amerikaner waren überrascht dass
gibson despot nix werden
so ist es auch bei diesen impfstoff
großen antwort zuerst da gewesen sein
mit so viel geld so vielen jahren
erfahrung und gepaart mit dem optimismus
dieses mal ist es kein zufall dass
folgendes im august 2020 geschah
putin behauptet russland habe den ersten
zugelassenen impfstoff gegen caen mit 19
am 11 august wurde das boot xv als
erster im stück weltweit für den
notfalleinsatz lizenziert diese
genehmigung wurde von der russischen
regierung erteilt basierend auf die
studien der ersten beiden phasen die
veröffentlicht wurden
was denkst du dass damals jeder dieses
zulassung toll fand natürlich nicht
diese entscheidung wurde von stil
kritisiert da die endgültigen daten aus
der studie noch fehlten und eine reihe
von zweifeln zu posieren
wie ist es möglich dass russland eine
impfstoff vor anderen ländern wie den
usa deutschland oder großbritannien
entwickeln und zu lassen konnte zu
dieser zeit waren alle extrem skeptisch
auch wir je bei visual politik weitere
tests bestätigten jedoch schnell dass
der impfstoff funktioniert und er ist
billiger als die andere
zum vergleich mit zehn dollar pro dosis
ist als 60 prozent billiger als moderne
58 trotzdem billiger als weiser bei
kontakt mit anderen worten gleiche
wirksamkeit aber niedrigere preist und
was noch entscheidender ist günstigere
logistik eigentlich ist also der
wettbewerbsfähigste impfstoff von allen
russland können sie den internationalen
markt über rennen allerdings putin ist
dafür das dezent darauf der welt so
schenken das heißt dass jeder auf der
welt diesen impfstoff herstellen könnte
ohne an das gamma institute gebühren
zahlen zu müssen
aber warum sollte russland auf das
milliarden business mit der krone
impfung verzichten wollen wir werden
diese frage gleich beantworten denn
zuerst müssen wir das wahre problem mit
dem russischen impfstoff verstehen die
kehrseite einer zentrale gelenkten
wirtschaft die russen haben top
wissenschaftler und können ihre
ressourcen stark fokussiert einsetzen
das haben wir verstanden aber reicht
dies wirklich aus um impfstoffe so
schnell herzustellen wenn du treuer wir
so alt politik zuschauer bist weißt du
bereist das eine gute formel nicht
ausreicht um eine impfstoff herzustellen
man muss ihnen auch gut testen und
schließlich irgendwie massenweise
herstellen und das ist ein wirklich
komplizierter prozess um die eine
vorstellung zu geben ende 2020 sagte ein
so großes unternehmen wie pfizer dass
sie im jahr 2021 nur 1,1 milliarden
dosen herstellen können tatsächlich
haben sich die impfkampagne europa
aufgrund von lieferengpässen verlangsamt
wie ist es also wirklich dass russland
alle hatte
ist die impfstoffe für alles sein 144
millionen einwohner zu produzieren
und da noch mehr um es zu exportieren
tja die kurze antwort dazu lautet es ist
dazu überhaupt nicht in der lage
zum vergleich als wir dieses video
drehte waren nur ein bruchteil der
russischen bevölkerung dms ganz anders
als in israel den usa oder selbst der eu
irgendwas ist da doch faul wie so
überschlägt sich russland so darin
seinen impfstoff in alle welt zu
verkaufen wenn es noch nicht einmal
genug für die eigene bevölkerung hat nun
du bist nicht der erste der sich diese
frage stellt aufgepasst
wir fragen uns immer noch warum
russlands theoretisch millionen und
abermillionen von impfdosen anbietet
während es bei der impfung des eigenen
volkes nicht ausreichend vorankommt juli
vorstellen kannst stellt die russische
regierung diese frage als propaganda
gegen russland ab viele europäische
länder haben jedoch eigenständig über
den kauf von russischen impfstoffen
verhandelt ganze geologie und
vorurteilsfrei isabel die us-
präsidenten in der autonomen region
madrid wird weiterhin über den kauf des
russischen impfstoffs verhandeln um die
immunisierung madrids zu beschuldigen
isabel die juso ist gerade frisch
wiedergewählt worden
und hör dir mal an die erfolgreicher
wahlkampf slogan lautet kommunismus oder
freiheit wenn ist also eine politikerin
gibt die abneigung gegen russland alles
was es präsentiert haben könnte dann ist
es genauso doch was die impfstoffe
angeht spielt ideologie nur eine
untergeordnete rolle
aber wir sprechen nicht über reine
verhandlungen es gibt auch eu-länder die
von worten zu taten übergegangen sind
eines davon ist die slowakei
[Musik]
die slowakei das zweite land der
europäischen union das boot mit v
empfängt und genau hier kommen die
probleme ins spiel
auf dem papier ist sputnik v ein
fantastischer hilfsstoff aber als die
slowakei die 200.000 von russland
gelieferten dosen wenn er analysierte
kam die große überraschung
diese impfstoffe also das einzige was
sie mit der ursprünglichen formel
gemeinsam haben ist der name staatliches
institut für arzneimittel kontrolle da
mal erscheint demnach so was wie das des
impfstoffes zu sein
zwischen dem was du bei gamona bestellt
hast und was bei die ankommt besteht
wohl tekla tanter unterschied die
slowakische gesundheitsbehörden
beklagten sich außerdem das nicht von
den russen kaum informationen über den
impfstoff erhalten haben und falls du
das jetzt für einen schlechten witz
hältst die slowaken fand die geschichte
gar nicht witzig dieser impfstoff
skandal wurde in der slowakei zur
politischen bombe tatsächlich musste der
slowakische premierminister aufgrund der
massiven kritik am kauf des russischen
impfstoffs zurücktreten wenn seine
regierung hatte recht versagt und ja was
vollkommen richtig gehört es gibt noch
länder in denen eine komplette regierung
die größe besitzt verantwortung zu
übernehmen und geschlossen zurücktritt
wenn sie scheiße baut ja ich weiß dass
das für viele von euch die von einem
fernen planeten klingt regierungen die
verantwortung für ihre eigenen
entscheidungen übernehmen und deswegen
auf ihrer macht verzichten auch mal
andere ans ruder lassen wo kämen wir
denn da hin und damit wären wir auch
schon bei der kehrseite der allmächtigen
zentralisierten lenkung ist mit der
haben sie es nämlich auch in puncto in
russland zu tun
wir können die sozusagen das tschernobyl
syndrom nennen der russische staat kann
seinen staatlichen instituten zwar viel
geld geben um den impfstoff zu
entwickeln aber wer stellt ihn her
hier kommt ein schlüssel konzept aus der
ökonomie und spielt die
wertschöpfungskette denn um die perfekte
formel für eine hilf stoff zu erfinden
braucht man vielleicht nur einen
brillanten wissenschaftler aber für
seine massenherstellung braucht man ganz
viele brillante experten in der praxis
100 das unternehmen dem stoff fabriken
zulieferer logistikunternehmen wir
sprechen hier von einem riesigen
netzwerk miteinander verbundene firmen
der staat kann zwar qualitätskontrollen
auferlegen aber es ist fast unmöglich
eine solch komplexes netzwerk zu liefern
perfektes zusammenspiel aus dem stand
heraus quasi das fingerschnippen zu
erschaffen
und selbst wenn dies versucht wird geht
es meistens schief
tatsächlich würde genau diese art von
vielen einschätzung super gau von
tschernobyl die technologie in diesen
atomkraftwerk war nicht unbedingt
schlecht die sowjetischen atomphysiker
waren mindestens so gut wie die in den
usa japan und westeuropa aber pläne sind
eine sache ihre umsetzungen eine
vollkommen andere am bauprozess waren
unternehmen beteiligt die den wettbewerb
auf einem freien markt ihn ausgesetzt
waren
sie mussten sich nicht gegen bessere
konkurrenten durchsetzen sondern einfach
nur das tun was ihnen von oben verordnet
wurde
eigeninitiative und mitdenken war nicht
nur unerwünscht sondern wurde bestraft
und genau hier wird dann die probleme
denn wenn die strukturen da oben ein
verkrustetes autoritäres system sind in
den dicht kompetenz zählt sondern
getrieben unterstrich reid hat man die
perfekte formel für an glaubt wenn es
eine sache gibt die diktaturen
charakterisiert dann ist ist
intransparenz denn intransparenz
bedeutet immer viele viele lügen und
lügen bedeuten keine fehler korrektur
und effiziente prozesse in einigen
fällen führt dies nur zu
kostenexplosionen und mangelnder
konkurrenzfähigkeit
aber im fall von tschernobyl führte es
zur explosion eines kernreaktors also
kommen wir zurück zu der frage von
vorhin wie bei russland in der lage so
viel impfstoff in so kurzer zeit
herzustellen
ihr kennt nun die antwort es war nicht
in der lage dazu russland hat keine
leistungsfähige pharmazeutische
industrie in der lage wäre impfstoffe in
solchen massen zu produzieren
gleichzeitig will es aber auch auf
biegen und brechen impfstoff auf den
internationalen markt verkaufen das
ergebnis vier der impfdosen die von
russland verkauft wurden haben nicht
alle notwendigen qualitätskontrollen
bestanden
das ist in der slowakei passiert und es
könnte auch in anderen ländern passiert
oder anders gesagt es war vielleicht
etwas kleiner zahn jahr zu stellen mit
denen dann die in den fachzeitschriften
publizierten tests durchgeführt wurden
als eine massenproduktion in gleicher
qualität sicherzustellen
das misstrauen vieler staaten gegenüber
sputnik v bezieht sich also nicht auf
die labor formel sondern auch die
verlässlichkeit der massenproduktion und
ich weiß dass viele von euch denken
visual politik ist wieder dabei russland
zu bashen wer hat euch dafür bezahlt
diese sex videos zu drehen was bozoljac
oder manuell aber nein
entspann dich denn jetzt kommen die
wirklich gute nachricht für den
russischen impfstoff also gerade in der
radierung ist höher auch dazu
[Musik]
warum russland keine patente will
sputniks v ist der einzige rohstoff mit
einer eigenen website und einem twitter
profil der letzte strohhalm zu dem der
kreml griff um das vertrauen in seinen
impfstoff zurückzugewinnen und ich fest
dass hat tatsächlich funktioniert die
daten lügen nicht argentinien erhält
neue lieferung von sputniks hilfsstoffen
insgesamt 4,38 millionen dosen gegen
kuwait erste charge des russischen
impfstoff sputnik phau trifft in den 1
aber warum kaufen diese staaten
sportback und nicht andere impfstoffe
die antwort lässt sich in zwei worten
zusammenfassen ideologie und
notwendigkeit sowohl argentinien als
auch in den haben ideologische und
kulturelle wende und zu russland aber
dass wir in einem anderen video
die wahrheit ist dass sowohl indien als
auch alle intimen es sich nicht leisten
können teure impfstoffe wegweiser
biotech oder moderner zu kaufen hinzu
kommt dass fast die gesamte produktion
dieser firmen bereits von reichen
ländern aufgekauft wird das fazit der
stoff passt genau zu diesen ländern
mehrere studien haben gezeigt dass er
funktioniert und es gibt sogar eine
echte erfolgsgeschichte ein land welches
das große hilfe des gremiums bereits
besiegt zu haben scheint von welchem
land hier die rede ist aufgepasst
[Musik]
san marino erstes europäisches land das
kogit 19 mit sputnik besiegt san marino
natürlich wir sprechen hier über eine
mikro start mit nur 34 1000 einwohnern
das heißt massenproduktion ist hier gar
nicht notwendig zum zeitpunkt des drehs
dieses videos waren bereits 90 prozent
der bevölkerung von san marino kämpft
und sie hatten seit dem 27
keinen einzigen todesfall mehr klar
hochwertige impfstoffe in solchen mengen
herzustellen liegt eben noch innerhalb
der kompetenzen des kabel eins tut die
qualitätskontrolle einer charge von
60.000 impfstoffen scheint für sie kein
problem darzustellen aber was passiert
wenn wir über große länder wie
argentinien oder indien sprechen ist ist
für russland wirklich möglich die
qualität von millionen von impfstoffen
zu garantieren wie wollen sie das
bewerkstelligen
nur schon immer folgendes an
astrazeneca und da ist kann man ja
institut unterzeichnen ein kooperations
memorandum mit dem ziel alle
möglichkeiten der internationalen
zusammenarbeit zu nutzen um den sieg
über die infektion mehr drehen
mit anderen worten russland liefert das
know how und astrazeneca liefert die
verbringt und ich weiß was du an dieser
stelle der ist astrazeneca haben die
nicht ihren eigenen impfstoff warum
sollten sie die impfstoffe anderer
firmen herstellen wollen und ja in
diesem punkt fast nur mit einer skepsis
recht astrazeneca wird beide ämter
herstellt ihren eigenen und die
russischen aber selbst das wird von
moskau nicht ausreichend um ihren
impfstoff in großen ländern wie indien
zu vertreiben und jetzt kommen wir der
antwort auf unsere frage von anfang
dieses videos näher
warum ist russland bereits ein patent
auszugeben nun genau aus diesem grund
russland und indien vereinbaren die
produktion von 200 millionen impfdosen
pro jahr
wenn er wusste als stoff in
massenproduktion herstellen will bleibt
ihnen nichts anderes übrig als mit so
viel pharmaunternehmen wie nur möglich
zusammen zu arbeiten
wir reden hier nicht von großen marken
die preise sondern von unternehmen die
sich auf die herstellung von generika
verschrieben haben und generika sind
eben arzneimittel deren patentschutz
bereits abgelaufen ist in china gibt es
bereits vereinbarungen mit unternehmen
zur produktion von 260 millionen
impfdosen in argentinien wird
rückschnitt 100 millionen dosen
produzieren du kannst ja also vorstellen
das ist für russland viel einfacher sein
gehirn zu finden die ihren impfstoff
herstellen wenn sie das patent
verschenken oder zumindest sehr billig
anbieten und dies gilt besonders für
arme länder im gegenzug erhält der kreml
dafür mehr einfluss in regionen wie
lateinamerika und indien stichwort
diplomatie aber das ist ein komplexes
thema für ein ganz anderes video was die
öffentliche gesundheit betrifft könnte
der russische impfstoff eine sehr gute
nachricht für alle seit allerdings wird
seine wirksamkeit stark davon abhängen
wer ihn herstellt es wird länder um
labore geben
bessere qualitätskontrolle haben als
andere wir werden also
höchstwahrscheinlich länder sehen in den
sv einen guten schutz bietet und länder
in denen es probleme geben wird aber was
willst du glaubst du dass die eu und die
usa den russischen impfstoff gnädigen
werden inwieweit könnte dieser impfstoff
das so die in russlands einfluss in der
welt zu steigern
teilt eure meinung wie immer mit uns und
auch einen anderen
kommentarbereich unter diesem video ich
hoffe dass es euch gefallen hat was ja
gibt uns bitte einen like teil dessen
freundin und vergesst nicht unseren
kanal auch zu abonnieren
was gut und bis bald
[Musik]